polémique démasquer cet autre polémique
le gouvernement aurait-il dû maintenir
le premier tour des élections
municipales
non selon la maire sortant de la commune
de clarensac d'un guerre paraît lui face
à son opposant qui a récolté plus de 52%
des voix un vote qu'elle conteste elle a
donc déposé un recours à cause du faute
du fort taux d'abstention et qui s'est
levé dans sa commune à 40 8 %
elles demandent de nouvelles élections
ce scrutin que je considère bafoué par
des consignes et des contrebandiers qui
ont pu être donné quelques jours avant
les élections
beaucoup de gens nous ont signifié ne
pas être venu voter parce qu'il donne
tout simplement entendu à la télévision
qu'il fallait limiter ses déplacements
et rester à domicile alors dans le lot
vous retrouver celles et ceux qui
écoutent de façon très disciplinés les
consignes des pouvoirs publics
et puis vous avez 7 et ceux qui sont
fragiles d'un point de vue de santé et
qui nous ont exprimé au qui m'ont
exprimé très directement le fait d'avoir
d'avoir une peur pour leur santé des
gens qui seraient suffisants
respiratoires et qui ont préféré avec
roman d'ailleurs rester à leur domicile
et pour les habitants de 45 900 sion
n'est pas une excuse valable pour
annuler le premier tour je pense qu'elle
n'a pas lieu d'être
il faut savoir être bon perdant quand
les habitants de clarensac vote pour
quelqu'un
voilà le premier tour il a il a décidé
que et bien elle était plus maire du
village
il faut laisser ceux qui viennent
d'arriver il faut les laisser en poste
maintenant pense qu'elle n'est pas
fondée
parce que bon ben vu l'écart qu'il ya
trop pourquoi il y aura une annulation
c'est parce que ce qui demande la lune a
sion c'est des mauvais perdants c'est
tout là c'est un peu facile entre
guillemets dans le sens où le premier
tour a été a été fait c'est je pense que
même si elle s est annulé il repassera
quand même c'est un premier jet de
d'apparemment des habitants de clarensac
donc
bon annulé tout ça parce qu'elle a perdu
je suis pas sûr que ce soit vraiment la
peine quoi